this video is sponsored by one of my
personal favorite Services rocket money
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation it's time to get
your reach
on reach on to John John how you doing B
I am Russo excited for the penultimate
EPG that's good to hear Rosco hey ladies
and gentlemen what you think about this
episode tell us your thoughts in the
comments below why don't you leave a
like on this video that'd be cool and
that' be cool John they subscribe too
John be the awesome we're interacting
with each other report hey guys prepper
thank you for helping us on these
highlights you guys are killing it also
full in 3 from watchong reing with your
own copy of Reacher episode 7 and uh
it's all our Reacher reactions full in 3
watch recing with your own copy
available for our super sex rejects over
at our patreon page we also cover
several things exclusive over there with
highlights and watch alongs included all
righty I'm ready to do it you ready to
do it we're all ready to do it let's get
do
it
all right we need to get you two out of
town to somewhere safe Jack father
everyone I trust with my life or anyone
else's is already involved in this thing
even Finley up in Boston
what Rosco Rosco who's Rosco the
greatest women ever the greatest Chicken
in waffles ever she's a friend back in
margrave we prefer her I prefer her got
competition a few months after I was
discharged I went to Buffalo worked in
House of this de Club ction agency it
was a dirty business did you write while
you were there private residence
apartment over a garage no property
records landline just my cell phone non
local area code utilities NOP included
in the
rent anyone there you trust my landlord
Bob Lee retired firefighter old school
Irishman a trustworthy landlord it won't
be forever we just need to kill a few
more
people I want to say that to somebody
there's a shitload of options at the
vending machine so I kind of got a
Samplers pack there a very veritable
schoras
board um can we have candy or do we need
to talk about murder
someone all in all she seems to be
handling it all right yeah hey Clark
bars Clark
bars oh no killer Reacher it's the only
Clark
Bar he looks so
dejected NE and I have business with who
Marsh Russo's Bots Russo confronts him
about being dirty and dies within hours
I'd say we have a lot to talk about so
enough oh my God possible thumbnail and
that must mean he truly is dead a good
man died in my arms last night whatever
you do to Marsh make him feel it he'll
be back we didn't see it happen you know
the rules that's true we didn't see the
the death rattle we didn't see the mor
cover this shopsy you cut open my body
is that the going price of an honest
cop's life these days I did not want
Russo to die all right the guy worked
under me since he was a rookie that's
why you couldn't do it yourself I told
Langston that Russo was on to him but I
didn't think in a million years that
they would kill him why not I figured
it' wise up when they dropped a bag of
cash at his feet like that one yeah who
the hell wouldn't take this kind of
money Russo wouldn't Jack Reacher
wouldn't so when you called Langston you
knew exactly what would happen he talked
about not being dirty and taking
envelopes all the time I really think
you can grab it and fire before I do or
you can tell me what I want to know and
use that phone to turn yourself in
you're just giving jack an
excuse go for the gun just do it
thumbnail
yeah you just use up your last bit of
Goodwill
oh we know the buyer mmud Mason Marino
or what a shot and that he due to meet
with Langston and a new age engineer to
get the little wi software chips
installed in the hardware I need to know
when and where that meeting is taking
place what the you talking about nobody
ever said anything like that to me oh my
God ow broke his Jack femur Grant would
know who's Grant the guy you ran over
last night he's dead he's not turn turn
on the news he's not dead he's in
intensive care in Mount
Si being an honest cop isn't that hard
just ask Russo oh wait he's dead can't
F dude you might as well take the money
now Jack yeah temptation this is the
moment turn it away give it to the kids
light it on fire he needs a little bit
give it to Russo's extended family
whoever was in his
life for my suits and clock bars you
don't know exactly how much is there a
would to grab just a little bit for
yourself no one's going to be looking
for you in Buffalo but where are these
pull them down tight low to your
eyebrows small precaution big benefits
right Works in every Marvel movie
driver's Got 5 grand cash in Pocket that
guarantees you a safe trip to Dixon's
friend's place she's like who's Rosco
who's Rosco who's Rosco got to hunt this
woman
down this isn't going to do I know
everyone thinks it's cool to warm
straight friend but I'm trying to bring
back the classic look want to help me
out keep hats great again how's
that good does look better it does look
better it's a lot better okay well uh
typically it's hard for women to say
goodbye to me so let's get you girls out
of here before you get to
ATT she's definitely pregnant with
Jack's kid Lord knows they don't wear
protection son of the reacher you know
we got this reer NE and I you don't have
to finish this out uh let him die it
means you've got more at stake than the
rest of us if you want you can walk away
with your chin up with my chin up nah
really going to try and pull that line
with me it was worth a shot let get back
to work buddy that this conversation
could have uh behooved them a little
earlier in the season I just want to to
make sure you understand the
ramifications of going through with this
Reacher I know that tonight will be the
culmination of two years of incredibly
hard work by every member of this team
absolutely I know that defying a direct
order will permanently damage and
possibly end career paths we'll be
taking out an operation pumping
thousands of kilos of heroin into the
country and we'll be making sure the
criminals hiding behind the name of the
United States Army know they can't do so
with impunity damn dude if any of you
don't want to be involved I understand I
couldn't respect you more it's reasons
like this why they fall Jack rer in a
battle and every one of you are free to
walk out of here right now with your
chin held
[Music]
high follow him in a battle it's a great
shift in all the body
language let's get to work Sho rack
Reacher they're here
Lieutenant oh yeah don't move hands out
and up major Jack reach at 110 military
police special investigations unit we
have reason to believe the these
vehicles have been used to transport
schedule one narcotics NE with your
fingers in a lock behind your head while
we conduct our
search you don't have a warrant this is
the military we don't need a search
warrant on your knees Uncle Sam is my
search warrant watch these soldiers
still call them soldiers if they do not
find it maybe they were tipped off yeah
maybe swans song or by somebody else on
the crew you never
[Music]
know maybe Dixon was encouraging to go
home to get him out of the way they're
destroing a lot of military
gear damn it perhaps you were
misinformed ass is
bad cut open the tires cut open the
[Music]
spares odonnell switch
blade hey hands up hands
up
[Music]
oh nothing rides like a heroin Tire or
some Sparrow in got a patch on this one
too you know that over here they're on
all of them that's clever that's a bust
you're under
[Music]
arrest my buyers might have something to
say about
that light them
up as they swiss cheese the whole Supply
awesome oh this how he
dies
oh come on
dude live in these flashbacks a little
longer
no wow
[Music]
nice
resourceful underrated action pose this
sort of like flushed on the
ground yeah little
[Music]
Kingpin grab one of theirs like a video
game nice God so sexy
Jesus
Christ that was
[Music]
legit that's some menacing ass
music ow got a
runner Jack Runner Kite
Runner
car has a
personality you got this man yeah I
remember basic training who whoa great
St work now back up over
him you broke my leg of course I broke
the fence broke the other one broke your
leg Yeah just throw them over your
shoulder had these printed out in case
anyone wants one you know kind of sort
of keepsake thing there go a goddamn
photo did Jack have an opportunity to
take one and pass it
up let me help you here we go Freebird
extended version extended version but I
got something even better cuz we sure
did go crazy on those sons of [__]
didn't we oh we going
[Music]
heart
what
[Music]
yeah you
crazy on you your unit is dispatched
each and every one of you will be
disciplined maybe not officially rest
assured Uncle Sam will get his pound of
Flesh the only one not standing in the
pose I told you how I wanted this case
wrapped up yes sir why' you
me if you're looking for an apology
there isn't one coming when you first
got the 110th all the brass said that
you would eventually get up glad I
didn't
disappoint 110th special investigators
unit you're all hereby relieved of your
duty you've all been officially messed
with where were
we 111th dismissed oh even
[Music]
cooler yeah my dude they knew what they
signed up for that's cool those are my
favorite flashbacks of them very back
and forth with enjoying the flashbacks
wish I had my piece any decent cop would
see the outline of a weapon in these
scrubs we go nice and easy get the info
we need and we're gone anyone to notice
that Buff Ass
nurse you know he just really cares
about his
health hi Grant whoa you yell or make
noise I'll tear your trachy out and your
last thought to be holy [__] he really
did
it you're a loose end who's going to be
questioned as soon as he's medically
cleared you don't think langson has
someone on the way here right now to
take you out I don't know
anything ohoh
what what going
mean let's make sure what are you going
to do with that catheter man C Reacher
what the
hell smart
smart oh
wow you know how a catheter works
there's a balloon inflated in your
bladder holding it in place if I fill
the balloon port with air it'll burst
the balloon and tear your uretha apart
like a
piñata
to be honest I'm kind of curious how
you'll react so if I were you I'd start
talking okay oh my
God
[Music]
no I can't understand a word he's
saying oh my
God L is me the V what time 5 D where
Lon keeps things on a needed no basis
that's it I swear keep it
going I swear to God I told you all I
know keep it
going lucky for you it looks suspicious
when your insights blow up Hospital
checks security cameras sees us coming
in here causes all kinds of trouble if
you have an embolism after a car
accident whoa no one suspects a thing
that is cruel this season I love it a
gift from gatan
[Music]
Russo wow man oh my God God he's like
The Punisher of this season that was
hard like methodical Punisher yeah he
wasn't this dark when his brother died
nope but you m with remember the 11 you
special
best you can jigsaw Reacher Dr scrubs
but look at the ccope only Nur carry
paper tape looks like he grabbed what he
couldn't Threw It on just like we did
and that guyy thinking I feel like these
two are talking about
me whoa okay I thought he was going to
just like trample That
Woman come out there was an action back
to episode yeah oh kill him with the
death scope I love how she's keeping
that on her head just in case anyone
suspects oh yeah
I don't like that we're alone and Neely
I don't like that this is a solo
moment this is the abandoned wing of the
hospital [__] it like a shotgun I don't
like it says caution I feel like it's a
[Music]
warning
damn got
me
thumbnail
yeah oh ouch damn this guy chose the
right room
okay yes wow great shot
neie ow
ow no let neie win this
one
yeah
keep him
alive wow keep him alive wow I wanted to
question him yeah true
yeah maybe we can still get some answers
good thing in this operating room is
this whole section is completely vacant
nobody at all in this wing of fully
supplied it's their backup hospital
since you maned a habit have taken out
my guys I've come up with my own
contingency plan and I've got two of
your guys they're the kids after the
untimely death of Officer Russo I had
the GPS on his Precinct car run visit to
the Jade East Motel a by hour tug joint
that that boy scout would never visit
unless he was working a case uhoh they
sent some of my boys over there and
guess what they found your pals yep damn
it what do you want I got an R&D
facility in Rockland County you and your
buddy Surrender Your Weapon and stay
under the watch of my men there till
this is over and then I'll let you all
go alive says a guy who doesn't like
loose
SS Assume My associates and I are have
$65 million and we won't have a reason
to kill you more bodies means more
[__] your cohort come here and this
is over for all of us before you know it
my cohort's name is neie and she's dead
your guy killed her in the hospital
basement and I slid his jugular with a
bone saw and I'm completely emotionless
about all this I'm I'm at the scene of a
double homicide waiting to be questioned
I leave now they start tailing me you
want them following me to you when I
show up need proof of life oh you'll get
it but if you try anything cute you'll
get proof of death hey hey nice they
shot all of Robert Patrick scenes in two
hours
yeah there's a jack margrave on the line
for you he says it's urgent Senator we
met at the
zoo I'm about to tear the apple cart to
pieces you still prepared to give me
everything I need your private security
former seals and Rangers two seals one
Ranger I need him well that's what it's
going to take to make all this go away
done oh boy I know that you think I'm
some feckless scumbag politician but I
was just trying to do right by our
country uh but I didn't know that it
would lead to people dying you got to
believe me on that yeah none of this
dangerous corruption stuff when
never Langston said if anything
suspicious goes down he'll kill Dixon
and odonnell there's no way to initiate
a plan from the outside without putting
them at risk that's why I have to do
this from the inside you have no idea
what he's going to do to you that's not
like you at all reach
yeah we saw France's autopsy record
cuffs torture no
Reacher don't worry I'm not just going
to lie down and take it it's not a Brad
it's a Fastener I told you punks this is
private property now beat it private
property starts at the fence man my
parents pay for this road with their tax
dollars not going to call the cops this
time I'm just going to kick all your
asses let's go
let's get a random action scene going
[__] oh and the fence is electrified
it's good thing those kids were there
just to establish that one we got to
recruit that
[Music]
kid is that a projectile in your hand or
you just happy to see me the new age
engineer who has the little one Chips
take me to
her
guy your pal reach you killed in the
hospital he's a good
man someone that you served with getting
violently killed I have no idea what
that feels like got his funny little
remarks funny little toys funny little
toys boom know these things don't do any
good if you don't keep them sharp how
about a funny little scream see how well
you maintain your
tools
okay
it's time I feel it I've been thinking
about operation Kite Runner lately
strange so have I we went into that case
knowing it was a losing proposition and
we all got burned sounds familiar kind
of getting that same Vibe now it killed
the 110th figuratively and now someone's
actually killing the on10th literally
you're about to walk into a bussa
Reacher we might die you might die
Reacher's been green Liv for season
three
yes people live in the and they die as
long as we do both properly there's
nothing much to regret true that this
all went to [__] you wouldn't be the
last member of the 110th for long they'd
kill you within 24
hours wink that wink weighs a lot
[__]
[Music]
as
let the man go
[Music]
through H the base the
beasts
up making his
[Music]
plan damn they got a
there goes the whole
plan
the
God these episodes been flying by thank
you to Rocket money for sponsoring this
video a brand that I am happy to be
partnered with thrilled to it's
fortunately one that I have been using
for quite a while now prior to every
agreen to a partnership with them I was
like that makes for the best kind of
synergy promotion because I can actually
talk about them from my heart here
reason being like many of you guys U
like for years I am constantly
downloading all kinds of financial apps
that I keep forgetting to use or I don't
really find quite as beneficial rocket
money has been the one the only one I'm
not just saying it is the only one that
I have been able to consistently use
rely on that has been an absolute game
Cher for me on a very personal note
running real rejects is an absolute
privilege however you know like I stress
out about taxes and it's the beginning
of the year and I'm like I'm trying to
be smarter and get it all done now I
already started like a couple months ago
getting things in order managing real
reject finances while managing my own
personal finances has been an ongoing
struggle and I'm very big on like
efficiency and being organized but
clearly wasn't as good enough as I uh
thought I had been so before rocket
money came into my life I was drowning
in subscriptions and struggling to keep
track of my expenses and as I really
wanted to like get everything in order
rocket money came at the right time for
me I was overwhelmed with subscriptions
I didn't even know I had or had still
been subscribed to I mean do you ever
wonder how many subscriptions you
actually pay for have you ever taken the
time to really do it it could be a
little daunting rocket money helped me
see what I was missing and best part
they even cancel those subscriptions for
me with just a simple tap so with rocket
money you can have all your
subscriptions in one place making it
easy to cancel anything unnecessary
without the hassle of dealing with
customer service my is so annoying plus
they'll work on getting you refunds and
negotiate lower bills saving you up to
20% you just snap a pick of your bill
and let rocket money take care of the
rest let me just summarize for you
really quick what they are their
personal finance app that findes and
cancels unwanted subscriptions monitors
your spending and helps lower your bills
with over 5 million users and over $500
million in cancel subscriptions they've
already saved members an average of $720
a year year they help save me a little
bit more than that don't waste your hard
earn money on unused subscriptions
cancel them today at Rocket money.com
reex that's rocket money.com rejects if
you've heard other people talk about
them well use ours rocket money.com
rejects cuz if you use that promo code
rejects you unlock special benefits and
yes using them is also a great way to
support the channel same time it's just
a great way to support your bank account
cuz I cannot stress enough just how much
this app has changed the game for me
take control of your finances with
rocket money and enjoy Financial p peace
of mind all righty guys well if you're
listening this to Apple or Spotify we
just watched Reacher episode 7 of season
2 and if you are watching this I don't
know why you haven't bought a shirt from
reject Nation shop.com yet in fact it's
pissing me off I'm going to deliver some
punishment to you and your family if you
do not go and support the channel in the
most awesome way by getting yourself
some re app Peril representing yourself
as a true member of the reject Nation
yes we run this S A Draconian type of
dictatorship lifestyle here yes if you
were to be a citizen citizen you cannot
Escape or flee this reject country
prisoner of the
reject
Penitentiary um all righty well John
take it away you were clearly having an
experience take it away oh I mean it was
a blast this episode really hit hard it
uh packed a lot of very tangible punches
and uh as the cresting into the final
episode of the season I mean yeah it was
a a white knuckler as they say a lot of
Great
Moments uh and and yeah like even though
it was such an action oriented episode
there were also some very nice and
impactful moments of bonding especially
with the one tenth that I appreciated
very much as you pointed out some of the
best flashback work the season probably
the best flashback the season has had th
far and uh and yeah there are a couple
of picks uh nits to pick when it comes
to that perhaps but uh but yeah I I I'm
just so excited for uh the next episode
what do you think I thought it was a
really good episode I thought it was
really good I mean it's more of like
season as a whole um perhaps little
criticisms here or there but in terms of
an isolated episode I thought it was
really good uh the action has been
really packing a punch and it's been I
think like they've focused a lot more on
upping the I've heard some debate about
how the action's been handled uh but I I
personally think the action has been
really well done like last episode's
action was I thought phenomenal and the
only thing that that kind of pulls me
out a tiny bit is when I'm become aware
of man they really choose like isolated
spots where normally I I feel like
there' be some occupancy taking place
here in this location uh outside of that
uh the the the violence itself seems to
be quite brutal and similar to like some
of the experience of Monarch there are
some things here in this episode that
only me a little bit
um uh how would I put it I I think some
stuff here that they
show might have aided the some of the
journey and making it attad stronger the
slightest bit stronger if we got some of
this stuff a little earlier you know and
and because yeah sometimes sometime some
of the stuff with the flashbacks has
been a bit of an up and down Journey For
Me of like I kind of feel like I'm
getting like information but not really
emotionally invested in what's happening
in these
flashbacks and while you know they're
all most of them are going to make it
out here alive uh in those flashbacks my
mind was going you know it might have
been cool to actually see them really
working together um at to the greatest
strength a little bit earlier in the
season and then I might have been more
invested in this whole like you don't
the on10th type of deal but I understand
that the dedication of the time frame is
not uh solely given to the past but this
was a lot of times when I'm watching the
flashbacks I'm not solely invested in
the flashback I'm more thinking of of
like the information to be getting I'm
not just caught up in the moment in time
I'm aware I'm constantly aware them in a
flashback basically like my my
mindfulness does not escape the uh um
the reality that this is going to end
soon and we will cut back to the present
yeah and this was the first time I
was we were there in the flashback for a
while and I and I was there with it like
as an episode like oh I'm actually just
here and I became aware of that oh I
haven't been thinking that we're going
to leave the flashbacks you know so I
thought there was like emotional weight
to it and it was the first time that I
really I feel like the show's been
telling me a lot about the
110th
and and uh what makes him such a
powerful core unit and this was the
first
episode and it's a little late in the
season but it was the first episode
where I finally really felt that instead
of just being told it you know and so
that's why I mean by oh I wonder if
there like some structural things just
as me as a viewer I know a lot of people
have I see that the the response on the
seasons it can be a little bit mixed
actually um like while the critics score
is higher than the first uh season I'm
I'm noticing that with audiences it is a
bit of a fluctuation where some people
are really not digging it and then other
people are loving it think it's better
than the first season and I'm not going
to say I'm in the middle I'm kind of
just like I get both I get both sides
and I just kind of have multiple
opinions about things and and none of
them are really in contradiction with
each other just yeah they're they're
parts of I'm like oh no this is good I
was like there elements of this that I
think would have helped the show
out um with being a bit stronger if we
just got those earlier it's not about
rewriting a season it's not about
structure it's about just taking in the
episode itself and I like what they're
doing with Jack Reacher uh I think he
packs a a great punch here and I like
the I like the body language of his
performance here it's really gripping
whereas he's a little bit more poised
and calm and in control and while
he while he's in control I think he's
demonstrating power over over others
this time around sure and then when he's
not in a position of power uh the rage
within him I think seeds even more uh so
yeah I think that's really neat and and
uh good violence and I did worry that
neie would die yeah in that moment and
uh yeah very obvious that we get
kidnapped when you have a whole scene of
you have more to lose it's like [__]
like that where I'm like I feel like you
could have had this expositional
conversation that's a very obvious
tropey conversation just like like Jack
reer is full of tropes like it is it's
part of the fun is the is the tropes
that take place that's how it makes the
tropes feel fresh and I think having
that a bit
earlier just would have even though it's
there you know you see he has a family
they talk about him having a family I
think putting that in the Forefront of
everyone's mind would have helped Aid
this so if he does make it out of your
Al which I think he will I think they're
all going to make it out of your life
sure totally honest you I think
everyone's going to live um it is cool
to see them really put up against the
wall right now like if you're going to
bring this the penultimate I think so I
think the next one is the finale yeah if
you're going to bring it to this far
into this season you want to push them
up against the wall and and it is about
if you know Jack Reacher himself is
going to be fine it's about endangering
the lives around him and I did and while
I think everyone will make it out of
here alive I I like feeling the sense of
everyone else being in danger I I did
the only time I was like oh maybe
they'll kill off Neely here um the I
think it's important to have that's
where the the real life or death Stakes
coming is not this whole like missile
taking over you know like the the world
domination and the power like that's not
going to do it uh it's and Jack
Reacher's life that's not going to do it
it's The Supporting Cast and I I think
putting our super our Avengers team in
this Peril uh bodess well for the show
overall yeah it feels like they are
walking into an approp appropriately
impossible feeling situation at the end
of this and that you know is a fun
Prospect for the end because yeah even
if you have the notion that you know
yeah the rest of our supporting
characters will likely survive this it's
still bolstered by the fact of like I
know Jackson Control and he's probably
going to figure this out but also I
don't know how he's going to do it you
know and so that's a fun Prospect but I
I do agree with uh some of the
criticisms you brought up because it's I
feel like in the first season the
flashback Motif was quite solidly
ingrained and it was often about giving
these specific moments but that feel
sort of tangental that speak something
to Jack fling out yeah was flushing out
the back story
yeah yeah and I feel like the the
flashbacks here have have gone for
elements of that but I feel like there
are maybe ways in which they could have
done it done it in a in a way that makes
it so that you know it's like we care
about the rest of the 1110th largely due
to Jack's dedication to them and we
trust Jack's judgment so like we can
assume that these are all great people
and the The Ensemble they have assembled
you know speaks to that as well and I do
like the scenes that we have seen but I
I do agree that it feels a little bit a
little less natural or a little less
like effortlessly complimentary to
what's happening in the present when I
think you have a really good opportunity
and they even like directly address in
this episode like man I'm getting
flashback Vibes to operation kit Runner
and the stuff that happened there and we
do see the operation happen but the way
it's been told through those flashbacks
it mainly feels like the operation
happened in this this episode
and I guess it it's it would be a tall
order to do because I can imagine it
expanding the season quite a lot but if
you almost like made it that it was like
a parallel like every time we cut to the
flashbacks we get some notable or
affecting piece of information about The
Ensemble but also are sort of watching
them crack a different mystery in real
time you can almost have like a dual
mystery thing happening together and
have the events of the past sort of
complementing the events of the future
and all that stuff um but again it's
that it's that thing of like for what
they have presented here I've liked all
that stuff thus far but yeah I could see
the ways in which it might be stronger
and I do feel like this season has even
still and even you know kind of coming
to that place I was hoping for a very
much enjoying it after starting off the
season you know just just kind of a
little less assured of what they were
going for uh you know it's I I
appreciate this but it does feel a
little bit more kind of packed with
things and and and action Ori oriented
and that does leave you I
think these these moments where you can
kind of slip over a Trope or have a
Trope that does kind of feel like a
Trope more than it would have maybe
before or something like that so it is
interesting and uh and and I well I also
don't like that um that they got
kidnapped and we didn't see how yeah
well and and that the only thing that
came to my mind when that happened was
like maybe you're right maybe Dixon's
working on the inside you know and and
and I've gone back and forth in the in
the intervening you know days between
you know the last episode or two and now
you know just thinking about that CU
part of me is like no I couldn't be and
you see her you know being tortured here
and you're like it probably wouldn't be
but at the same time I'm like oh maybe
no I doubt her now okay I doubt her now
yeah but yeah it's that thing of like
we I I get what you mean cuz it's like
we know how great all these people are
how finely tuned their instincts and
senses are so like yeah how did this how
did this happen when you've been nothing
but leveling this dude's henches like
this whole time yeah even if it's just
like her and neie yeah like I feel like
they could have gotten out of this but I
don't know how how they got taken yeah
yeah so maybe we'll see that and maybe
it'll justify it but at the same time
it's like what what special henches did
you save for this kidnapping mission
that you didn't deploy already yeah you
know um that's about it yeah but overall
though no it was a really enjoyable
episode uh it was very like gri from
beginning end Jack re are still the best
part of it all yeah and I love them all
singing together I thought that was that
was a moment where I really felt bonded
to the one0 and even the guy who's who
we know the least about the black guy
who's dead before all this stuff happens
like even he I was like I forget he's a
character until he shows back up in one
of these flashbacks and I'm like I kind
of am getting to that point that I would
have yeah liked to have had sooner of
having a clear idea of who each of these
people is and caring for them in a you
know peripheral sense at least and I'm
glad we got there eventually anyway um
yeah I just think
uh I can't help but kind of just Ponder
like I enjoy the episode a lot don't me
wrong and I feel like uh it could be
very misconstrued that uh criticism
means you hate
something I mean criticism often has
this like very negative connotation that
the word criticism means to critique but
that doesn't necessarily mean it is a
negative point of view overall and I
don't have a negative point of view
overall of the episode it just left me
with a feeling of wanting of ah this
might have just helped Aid some of the
experience sure and to know that they
could do it and that it was there I was
like oh if there was a way to have plac
this earlier like oh how that feeling
could have helped wash over a lot of the
rest of the season yeah and helped give
like different actual stakes and
concerns or investment you know just the
emotional side it's literally just the
emotional side is what I'm talking about
but yeah I mean still shot really cool
still looks really cool and it's still
engaging when when it's on screen and
it's funny at times and and um yeah I'm
excited to see what happens in this
finale F show so last episode was still
my favorite of the season Y um R Russo
that was still a very strong episode uh
yeah I the most I felt was probably when
Russo was
dying that that was like yeah I feel
like the emotional nothing to do with
the
one and and who for all intents and
purposes is is a distinct supporting
character but wasn't like even like the
most major supporting character no no so
his death is funny to me because it
feels like very significant and it is
but also when you add up the pounds for
pounds you know he's not number two or
three on the you know list of supporting
char character Effectiveness or or you
know even time spent focusing on them or
whatever you know yeah yeah but uh but I
mean look we're almost done with the
season and if I reflect back I don't
think any of The Supporting Cast
compares to Ros Finley yeah I don't
think any of them do yeah bottom line
like that that is probably the one I I
just don't feel like anyone even comes
remotely
close to
the caliber of Engagement that's all I'm
measuring it by yeah is being engaged in
who they are not like oh I wish they had
traits like them or I wish they were
like this Russo comes pretty freaking
close sure Russo comes pretty close and
even if anything he's he's like an Al
version of Finley you know honest cop
dealing with corruption yeah you know
that's who his character is and and is
another version of that yeah but he's
still so distinguishably different than
Finley and so many ways well they give
him beats that envelop or that develop
his character even in action yeah for
and for the episode that reminded me of
Rosco and Finley because they directly
brought them up yeah it did have me go
you know I'm nowhere near as anywhere
near as emotionally invested in in uh in
these guys as I am as I was Rosco and
Finley you know yeah I would agree it's
it the first season had such a a it felt
more like a book and I don't really know
how to describe that in a clearer sense
but like this this season feels more
like a movie version of Jack Reacher
whereas like the weird irony of coming
into the show the first time was like
okay I've seen this as a movie and I
know that that it differed from the
books that everybody loves and
apparently everybody loves this CU it's
capturing the essence of what the books
are and I'm sure that this is doing that
in some degree as well but it does feel
like the way it approached
characterization and atmosphere was a a
little different and a little more I
don't know uh it's not that it was like
any less action oriented but like there
was always a lot of like really
intriguing character work and you know
dialogues like whether it's unrelated or
whether it's people dissecting the
details of the case there just seemed
like a a different and a maybe greater
more lively intersection of just like
the life of the characters whereas so
much of what we're doing here is mostly
about the convoluted plot and the first
season also had a convoluted plot but I
felt like I was able to kind of balance
out those things and I wasn't as
concerned if maybe certain details were
overwhelming whereas here it's a little
bit like okay I got to make sure all the
details are on point because that's
mainly what we're doing
and and yeah it's going to take the the
final episode to really be able to
process the season it's also extremely
straightforward yeah like this is this
is an extremely straightforward uh
season yeah it's it's a straightforward
action procedural in a lot of ways yeah
with a lot of its charms still intact
but I feel like yeah like the whole
thing about the music which seemed like
a a personal motivator for Jack's
character like a personal detail that
might persist doesn't really feel like
it's engag here and like little things
like that or even just I don't know who
who he is is a no we're just not doing
much personal stuff strangely even
though we have you know like this
intimate connection with Dixon or
whatever and we have the camaraderie of
the team I don't feel like we're diving
beneath the surface all that frequently
this season whereas the first one had so
much of both you know I think and to it
I mean to be fair I
think the darkness that Jack succumbs to
and the acceptance of the darkness that
like NE like ne's always on ne's ever
like Jack you're going too far or you
need to hold back like no one's ever
encouraging him to pull his punches you
know if anything they're they are
dishing out like the pain yeah in a way
that's beyond a military unit doing a
mission like I mean that guy in the
hospital was murder like yeah he
tortured and murdered
someone like who did not need to be
murdered they're just in a hospital bed
yeah and so when it comes that's why I'm
saying Jack is still the most compelling
character and and that's a good thing
because it's the title character is that
watching The Darkness he falls
to even though perhaps there's an
arguments he made that if people were
like kind of like yo you're going pretty
dark man I mean I don't think Russo
would have wanted to do that definitely
not yeah all all things considered I
think that there should be some maybe
there could be a bit of a contrast which
would only shine a light further on the
darkness and and and enhance the
characterization of that uh I I think
you know what it if I got a level with
you guys I I think everything on a
technical level is pretty fine um it's
pretty strong still honestly I do it it
it's um I think it's the writing of the
Season that is just not as strong that
like that's the that's the M I know
everything I'm talking about when it
comes down to like is the one specific
section I'm like it's it's the writing
itself U the writing itself is hasn't
been as strong and um and not like the
writing is spectacular in the first
season but there's a there's a life to
it and and I think that that there are
qualities here that uh if if we're
talking about a book
adaptation for an action series at the
end of the day
there's only so far reading text of an
action scene will take you you have to
be very invested in everything else
outside of the action to keep turning
the page yeah you know you can't just
keep reading descriptors of fight scenes
and and uh this season seems to
accelerate at its best when it is in a
and about tension and action in some way
even if it's not like a full-blown fight
scene if there's like the torture of
murder scene in the hospital is like a
variation of an action
scene it's not like a choreograph fight
pun punch but it's a violent scene and
there's a menace to it so I feel like
that I could see how that's compelling
in like a book something like that right
or the chase to the hospital or the
fight there like this is this is when I
feel like this season is really firing
on all cylinders and that's what this
episode mainly demonstrated that's what
the last episode really demonstrated
really well although up until the finale
it was some pretty compelling ass the
scenes like the scenes themselves were
really that's why I thought that episode
was the best because I thought the scene
work was great yeah and and here it it
kind of it didn't I don't want to say it
it completely reverted back but I I felt
like once we got to
episode four I was like oh that was much
better yeah than five was oh that was
great and then six was that was amazing
yeah it just kept getting better better
better better and I thought like all the
things that I've been working really
work here in the flashback sequences
really worked strong too and it was the
stuff in the present day that wasn't as
compelling to me as I'm like ah but it's
been getting like progressively more
compelling and then it the present day
weirdly I was like oh the flashback
stuff got way more interesting but the
present day stuff didn't be as interest
didn't remain as
interesting uh as strong I would say
yeah and unless we were in some type of
violent adjacent thingy taking place
well yeah because I think Robert Patrick
is a terrible villain I think he's a I I
think he's awful here it is a bummer I
think the writing of him is awful not
the acting I think his acting is strong
I think the writing of him
uh doesn't demonstrate any real
strength and it's just cliche real
character and am is this weird thing
developing off off off the main timeline
it feels like it's like off the main
time it is on the main timeline it's all
very connected he even picks up the
missiles and [__] but it but it just
there's no like real interaction or a
cat and mouse game with him I should be
excited I should be feeling like oh my
God they're finally going to collide and
I just had to remind myself oh yeah I
guess the next episode they'll have to
collide they haven't yet yeah and and
and it's too I think the flashback this
episode gave you something that spoke to
the characters in a way that if that was
about what we've been doing in the main
plot but also was about just them as
characters and I feel like the inverse
in this episode with the present
timeline that kind of makes things feel
a little funky is that you do have this
dark streak in Jack that yes is
partially badass but I as a viewer and
I'm sure many viewers depending on your
Sensibility looked at that scene in the
hospital and was like this feels like it
could be Crossing some kind of a line
even though sure like the guy had it
coming for what he did to Russo and all
that but at the same time that could be
something worth unpacking like hey man
you're you're you're really getting dark
here you know and and that's part of
Jack's soul I feel like we love Jack
because he has a good grip on the line
and that's a fascinating thing to
explore but I we ain't gonna pack that
unpack that in like one episode
next week you know no that's a I don't
use the word murder lightly like that is
a murder moment yeah you know getting
into the fire fight with the buyers uh
is not I would not be like these guys
are murdering they technically are
harder killing yeah but
murder to use that word is like this
they there was
no reason to kill other than revenge
yeah like you know uh and it was cold it
was brutal and it was a compelling ass
scene and I hope it's not just dismissed
I even like I even like the idea of neie
being in on like Neely was game Russo
died in her arms you know so I think the
scene is is really strong and I like but
will a moment like that amount to
anything or we just supposed to go
badass he got you got the revenge you
know for you jack go go yeah yeah yeah
you know yeah and it's and it's yeah and
in in a season that didn't have some of
the elements we've been discussing here
I don't think I would be feeling that
necessarily or I think it would be
unpacked or it would be a theme CU he's
been a darker more direct kind of
Ruthless version of himself this season
which is again compelling but yeah I
don't feel like it feels like a choice
they made for how the character behaves
but not a choice they made for like the
life of the character and the
exploration of the character yeah but
those are our thoughts it's interesting
it's like an immediate moment it's like
that was really enjoyable and I but
there's something like kind of itching
in the back of my head I'm like I'm not
sure what it is about this particular
episode there's something like kind of
because you've experienced the greatness
that the writing on the show can have
before yeah I know and then it was like
it was pretty much there it was getting
like the like I said it escal I think it
was because it escalated too there and
then I I did feel like
a it was it was the same thing happened
with Monarch like oh it was a great
episode why wasn't this kind of
greatness here like I could have done
that
earlier yeah and it just makes me like
could have had this be a thread
throughout the season yeah yeah like
that that that thread that grows that
blossoms throughout a season is very
important for a for a hook I'm not
saying it's like a little too late or
some [__] maybe it's better on a
rewatch I don't know um and and May and
you know everyone's going to have
different viewer people who just watched
season one people who read the book and
watch this uh uh yeah everyone's going
to have like people some people might
not have even read this specific book
but they read other reer books and
watching this you know like there
everyone has like a different viewing
experience and this is just ours uh it
all our our experiences affect our
immediate experiences with the property
it's the way life goes it's life
experience at the end of the day Food
For Thought bunch of potenti mumbo jumbo
[__] all righty guys what do you
think about this episode leave your
thoughts down below thank you for being
here uh check us out for the finale
going in with uh with overthe toop just
way sky rocketing high expectations yeah
I want to feel like I never have to
watch anything ever again I'm not
expecting a 10 I'm expecting a 1 million
and if it does not come close I will
leave incredibly disappointed I am ready
to walk out of here with my expectations
not being fulfilled but I'm going in
expecting them to be fulfilled isn't
that ironic all righty guys well let's
send this to
the Ricardo Martinez it is
2024 we have entered a new year of
shoutouts for you Ricardo so I got to
guess where your resolution is going to
be this year and I imagine your
resolution will be to pop the zits on
your back cuz let's face it man once in
a while you might be standing in the
mirror mhm and you're going oh I got
this big zit on my back I don't have
anyone to pop it for me do I want to ask
my lover no n she might be turned off by
that what's the big deal anyway you know
like most people don't see my back most
of the time I have a shirt on do I need
to pop this zit really is it going to
affect my life it's imperative
well my friend I got to tell you for
those who see it they're going to want
to pop it and I'm telling you if you run
out of a conversation starter it's going
to come in handy you want to pop my zit
who could say no it is an instant way of
intimacy relatability cuz we all have
Backes we just we just lie about it we
all do think of the hottest girl you can
think of bam back covered in zits Kate
Beck and sale at 50
has
back K dun F50 bages full of backit man
it and you know what she's had them her
whole life boom all that kissing to
McGuire while he was upside down [__]
raining on zits the entire time my
friend yeah so and it's like so dude I'm
telling you it'll just make things um
you you'll feel lighter too yeah you'll
get a catharsis so pop your backets and
thank you for serving in the military
for us by the
way appreciate
[Music]
you